-Guys,
it is the end of the week.
And that's usually when I catch
up with some personal stuff.
You know, I check my in-box
or return some e-mails,
and, of course, send out
"thank you" notes.
-Whoo!
-Well, I was running
a bit behind,
so I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
"thank you" notes right now.
Is that...
[ Cheers and applause ]
James -- James, can I get
some "thank you note" writing
music, please?
♪♪
-[ Chuckles ]
-Alright.
You moved a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
A little bit of movement there.
♪♪
Thank you, candy corn,
for looking like
a 5-year-old's finger painting
of Donald Trump.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, apple picking,
for giving couples
who are tired
of getting into fights at Ikea
an outdoor alternative.
[ Light laughter ]
I'm going to put them
in the envelope later.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, wow, you're really
just phoning it in today, huh?
[ Laughter ]
There's no gloss.
-No, it's not --
no, there is no --
there's never going to be gloss.
-Okay.
So how come you're not putting
them in the envelope now?
Because it's the Apocalypse?
-No. I'm not doing it
because I figured --
well, it just takes
a little extra beat of time.
I'll -- I'll -- I'll lick
the envelopes on the next two.
-Dude, after like 17 years
of, like, you know,
"Thank You Notes"
where you put it
in the envelope,
now, okay, we don't even --
we can't even look forward
to that on a Friday.
Great.
[ Laughter ]
-Tariq, not everything
can be as glossy as your shoes.
[ Laughter ]
-Yo!
That's it.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
I saw you searching
and searching and searching.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
You got me. You got me.
Okay.
-Alright. Alright.
Here we go.
♪♪
Alright, come on, James.
Alright, here we go.
♪♪
Thank you, Dunkin's
new Spicy Ghost Pepper Donut
for explaining their new slogan,
"American gets runs on Dunkin'."
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
I did it for you.
That's for you.
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, pumpkin carving,
for teaching kids
that Halloween isn't just about
taking candy from strangers --
it's also about
playing with knives.
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, leaves turning red,
or as trees put it,
"OMG, this is so embarrassing."
[ Laughter ]
-Oho!
[ Chuckles ]
Ah. America gets runs.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you,
removing the A.C. window unit
at the end of summer,
for being the only chore
that leads to a possible
manslaughter charge
if I do it wrong.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
"Pack everything up.
We're moving."
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
♪♪
Thank you, hot stone massages,
for the calming sensation
of being branded.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it.
Those are my "Thank You Notes,"
everybody.